Guys, it's Tuesday. It is time
for "WeTweet." Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets, and we're all
gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep.
Look at the confusion there.
There you go. Perfect.
You can vote for all of
these tweets, by the way,
if you like them. We'll see.
You'll see the voting polls
when they come in.
You can vote for none of them
if you feel like
voting for none of them,
if you go like, "I don't even
want to play this, Jimmy.
Just do the work
and just leave me alone."
I understand. You're gonna
see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too.
-Got 'em.
-Now, have you ever
gotten close on this?
Like, have you chosen
the right one?
-Yeah.
I always choose the right one.
I've never gotten it wrong.
Have a perfect score
so far on "WeTweet."
-Alright. Let me see.
Here you go.
So, anyways, we're gonna vote.
Whichever one you like,
we're gonna tweet it out.
And then you at home
can like it and WeTweet it.
-Hm!
-It's a shared experience.
Thank you very much.
Don't vote on that joke,
by the way, please.
That one's a -- That one's
already making the show.
That's guaranteed.
Alright. This first tweet is...
-No. No.
♪♪
-You can't say no.
-Fro no.
-That's what the clickers
are for.
-Okay.
-They're not voice-activated.
-No!
-The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Oh, my God.
Come on!
-Come on, man!
No! No!
-Alright.
If you're in a hurry, you go,
"Hey, I need some fro yo,"
but if you're
in less of a hurry --
-You go,
"I need some frozen yo."
-Yeah.
-No, we got it.
-Yeah, I know you did.
This next one is --
There's this one.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Gosh.
-I don't know, man. Maybe --
I feel like I ejected.
[ Laughter ]
I mean...
I'm not feeling good
about this one, either.
But let's see the results
on this one there.
Alright. Hey.
-Oh. Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Okay.
So far, that's in the lead.
-131.
-We got three more.
So, if you really liked
that one,
you know,
don't play the game anymore.
Yeah.
-Just lock that one in.
-I feel like
that's going to be top.
-Yeah.
-Alright. The next one is...
[ Laughter ]
[ Jimmy laughing ]
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
"Um, hi. I thought
we said 9:00? What's up?"
-I like that.
-Yeah, that's pretty good.
Alright.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Whoa! Whoa!
-That's like a dead heat!
Wow!
-Whoo, whoop!
-That was a polarizer.
-Boop! Yeah, it was cool!
-Beeyoop!
-Yeah.
-Alright. Oh, I like this one.
Next up says...
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Got the -- got the --
Tariq liked that one.
Got a little giggle.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I'm gonna say 186.
-Alright. You think 186 people?
-Mm-hmm.
-That's almost like
a landslide vote.
-Yeah, landslide.
-Alright.
You think so, too?
-Yep.
-Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
-Whoa!
-Off by two!
-Fantastic bid!
-Wow!
-That's probably gonna be --
I feel like that's
gonna be the one right there.
-Well, maybe. Who knows?
This one might top it.
-No, I know.
That one's not gonna top it.
But here's the last one
just so you have it.
-Okay. Alright.
-We can change it.
It's up to you guys. You decide.
This is real-time. Here we go.
Uh, it says...
That's what the mug says.
-Do you think
you'd drink it like this?
Do you turn it as you drink it?
So it's like --
So you can read it.
-'Cause there's so many words
on the mug.
-Yeah, so you read it as you go.
-Yeah.
Or you get a larger --
-Or a huge mug.
-Mug, yeah.
Like a "Friends" novelty...
-Oh, yeah.
Like a comically large mug.
-Yeah, like a "Talk Soup"...
-Oh, yeah!
-Oh, my God.
-I forgot if I voted or not.
Anyway. It doesn't matter.
It's gonna be the zoo one
either way.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
Ah! I was right! There you go.
The winner is number four.
It is the zoo one, right there.
[ Bell dinging,
cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a wetweet and enjoy.